Rosario Dawson appeared as Ahsoka Tano
in both the Mandalorian and the Book of
Boba Fett replacing voice actress Ashley
Eckstein who voiced the character on
clone wars and Rebels Dawson was a big
deal long before entering the Star Wars
Universe making a name for herself in
projects including kids Clerks 2 Death
Proof and Daredevil playing Ahsoka is
clearly the role of a lifetime for
Dawson though the actor told Vanity Fair
that it's a part she hopes to hold on to
for a long time to come saying as long
as they want me and as long as it's
possible I'm in it Dawson's desire to
play the former Jedi does not seem to be
just because of the fame she'll get from
the Star Wars universe but because she
genuinely cares about and relates to her
character in an interview with IGN
Dawson discussed what drives Ahsoka she
noted that even though Ahsoka isn't a
Jedi anymore that desire to do good and
be of service Still Remains a part of
her we begin to see this in the
Mandalorian when she frees the people of
corvus from the control of magistrate
Morgan elsbad